hi I'm Kai from designer con check me
out on bootleg kev's podcast
bootleg kit podcast special guests in
here we got the homie Kai from 3D retro
and from designer con how you doing
checked in thanks for having me yes sir
uh so for people who don't know uh well
one I went to your store you have a
store in Glendale is it technically
Glendale it's technically Glendale one
block away from Burbank literally walked
us across the street is Burbank right uh
it's a crazy toy store
um and we have a mutual friend named DJ
amen who's a psychopath uh just buys
every uh just toy imaginable his house
is uh insane it's it's kind of like a
toy store yeah um so he's like yo you
should come over here check it out
because I kind of like toys I'm kind of
like you know
not like that though
um and I walked into the store and there
was so much [ __ ] and
um I didn't know that you also were the
guy behind designer con right so now you
got designer Con coming up
um what is designer con for people who
don't know so uh for people don't know
designer cones the annual collectible
convention this is our 17th year so Ben
is the founder I run the show with him
okay uh so we have artists from all over
the world from Asia Europe and off of
course the United States Independent
Artists illustrators and world renowned
toy makers and Painters so all of them
usually come to our show either exhibit
or have exclusive or have collaborations
we support everybody from the top to the
bottom the emerging artists everybody
it's kind of like the end of the year
party for collectors and artists is it
pretty is it kind of like uh revolver
it's like kind of like the
the underlying theme of it is like if
you're because it's called designer con
it's not called toy con so there's
there's kind of something there for
everybody as long as you're kind of into
like
creative [ __ ] like you said there's
people who are painting yes containers
illustrators uh toy makers vendors the
collectors and then there's the guys
that started just making [ __ ] out of the
garage they're like hey I want to make
something oh like they got a 3D printer
in there yeah exactly like so we it's
for everybody's everything in terms of
design so what got you uh initially
involved in the toy industry
ah so I I told this story a couple times
I was in high school I walked into a
Stussy on um is it Fairfax or La Brea
area they had this little figure of
their mascot holding a skateboard yeah
so that's my first thing man that's
pretty dope and then went to kit robot
they started coming out yeah 2003 2002's
so going to their store and be like this
is dope Japanese stuff and they just
told me that's their original design I
started buying and it just got hooked
just been buying buying and uh became a
seller uh later on just like got
wholesale account and did all that stuff
and then got into uh working with
different artists and then designer con
came around and basically just that's my
whole life so you started collecting
around 2002 yeah
um at what point in time did you decide
to get involved in the Commerce side of
it where you're like okay I'm a fan I'm
enthusiastic about just collecting yeah
but I also want to make this like two
thousand my business 2008 oh wait so two
thousand
2008 around that time I was working at
Disney Disneyland so I was uh I went to
school for Hospitality oh [ __ ] I went to
school for Hospitality management so uh
coming out of school a cordon bleu right
so coming out of school I got hired at
Disneyland doing what uh
um basically food service for employees
got you so basically I'm the I'm the guy
behind the restaurants so if you go to
Disneyland you see restaurants there's
restaurants for their cast members
employees so I was one of the managers
running did you see how close over there
I still know a few people there okay
actually what's funny is that you do
good Disneyland plug if you live in L.A
so I'll tell you something the guy that
designed our uh mascot designer called
mascot Scott Tollison yeah he's still a
Disney imagineer oh wow so he is super
busy right now because Disney's doing
some cool [ __ ] songs on some new cruises
so he got designer con that he's doing
he got he he's been working on our
member membership program a project that
we've been doing the last six months and
then he's got Disney wow like so we do
have some people that works during
designer con we know a lot of people in
different Studios of course of course
artists and all that so you go from
working at Disney
yeah this is what you went to school for
went to school for yeah yeah and uh I
think it was the recession the first
that recession 2007 2008 so I was laid
off yeah I got laid off and at that
point in time I'm like
uh I have all these toys and I have all
these vinyl figures I feel like people
buy them I buy a lot of them yeah let me
see if I can get a wholesale account and
and then start a business myself yeah so
at that point I actually sold all my
sneakers in 2007 to get funding to buy
more toys to sell how much did you get
for all your sneakers and like at that
point was like 10 15 reps wow and the
price is not like what it is now right
it's kind of back in the retail Market
is kind of crazy back in the day in that
I think I have mostly
um SBS and Jordans yeah SBS was on its
way down so I was like just got rid of
it just got off of them but that's what
funded you being able to buy more toys
through your wholesale account right so
at that point I decided to get a
wholesale account and buy stuff to uh to
uh
to make money instead of you know I'll
collect I'll keep some but may need to
sell and try to make a living out of it
yeah and uh yeah that's when I became
like a lot of harder smells like white
in line collect their [ __ ] and now it's
like oh here it's kind selling stuff
yeah so so was that the beginning of 3D
retro uh 3D retro so Ben funded uh
founded 3D retro around the same time in
2003. okay so he he basically he and I
were business partners right so what we
did is um he ran an online shop 3D retro
was online and uh I was basically buying
with him I was the guy behind the scene
so let's say there's a new product came
out for wholesale
um you have to buy a certain amount to
get a good price and Ben only wanted uh
like say 10. you buy the difference to
get the better price yes and then I
would you would flip and do your thing
yes I will do my thing yeah so that I
that's what I how most artists know me
and I would be supplying not just 3D
retro I personally I would be supplying
other stores too because I got an
account overseas at that time a big
company an artist called Ashley wood
doing 3A stuff so yeah so that's how I
kind of got all connected with everybody
and uh 3D retro band
um decided to open this door yeah and
designer con started growing so he uh he
asked me to come on board nice with him
that's basically the the story of how I
with Ben and through the Retro and
designer con what up you always stop in
the interview real quick to tell you
about our good friends at my bookie
we're live in my room right now in Las
Vegas and if you're not in Las Vegas
like me and you want to gamble on Sports
and the easiest most convenient way you
want to get that money man listen NFL
season we got college football we got
NBA going stupid right now all you got
to do is sign up right now at my bookie
using the promo code bootleg and they
will match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars that's right whatever
you deposit of two thousand dollars
they're gonna match that they're gonna
give you free money to gamble with so
what the [ __ ] are you doing inflation is
crazy everybody can use some extra money
they're gonna give you some free money
to play with if you make your first
deposit using that promo code bootleg up
to a thousand dollars they're gonna
match it uh I'm gonna tell you what this
weekend
Cardinals versus Niners Monday Night
Football Mexico City
I don't like my Cardinals go heavy on
them Niners all right that's all that's
my bet for the week all right let me
know what you gotta hit me on Instagram
and all that don't forget to sign up and
get this money with me at my bookie all
right go to my bookie right now stream
games bet on them you could live bet
them you could do the props and of
course they got the live casino all that
mybookie promo code bootleg sign up
right now and they're gonna match your
money up to a thousand dollars let's get
back to the interview now what is the
most expensive toy that you guys have
sold
not not retail I mean maybe it is retail
I don't know like let me know what is
like the the biggest toy you guys sold
after market and then obviously yeah a
single item right yeah single item uh a
single item that the most expensive
single item we've ever sold
is about ten thousand okay uh it's a one
thousand percent beverage and that was
retail
that was the retail that was retail it's
it's made out of wood
wow and we only had one and we sold it
in the pandemic we decided ah we don't
know if I'm gonna be gonna put it up so
we had our designer come 2020 yeah I'm
doing live stream so we put it up so
within like under a second it was gone
wow right uh but the last two years
we've sold like eight thousand dollar
ones yeah it was a carbon fiber one
thousand percent fabric through the
store uh I sold it to uh a musician I
don't know if I can say okay
I don't think they care uh muster bought
it mustard yeah he's special ordered it
because I was like if you want this this
is the price you know retail yeah so
mustard bought an 8 000 bear break
carbon fiber wow that's pretty it's
light but it's specially made you know
would you say Mustard's got a pretty
crazy toy collection ah
I I think I helped him a little bit on
that yeah he he liked the one thousand
percents so uh if he comes to me like
hey what you got yeah so you know we we
our store carries like you saw yeah you
guys have a lot of stuff but certain
special ones that we only get a few
pieces so I will call
like hey you know like I only got two
right you know if you want them what
about Ben ballerina this is huge with
the bear bricks and he's got a crazy
tour collection is he somebody who
you've supplied stuff for in the past uh
yes we we uh we work we dealt in the
past yeah I got him uh Nike SB bear
bricks like we got like three in
obviously I keep one yeah Ben keeps one
I got one for sale so so when you guys
keep stuff
you are you are a collector still to
this oh yeah yeah
so what's your house look like
a mess a mess uh a lot of toys and
sneakers I'm a sneaker you came you saw
all the sneakers and you bought them
back oh yeah yeah obviously yeah uh what
got me back was the Kobe 8s actually so
I got into sneakers in 2001 or two for
from SBS right but I got back in from
the Kobe 8s uh because they were all
about art at that point in my life I
like designers toys art right so the
Kobe 8s were all about art and tristanin
which is a friend and artist
um he did something with at that time
there's a Nike vault at Staples Center
right crypto.com whatever there's a
store there he did a special sock with
the one of the preludes so like all
everything's about art the whole
model you know so I just got back into
it somebody who might not be famous just
a customer you have in mind like who who
like how crazy is like your guys's
biggest customers toy collection
so uh I'm sure you have a few we do cool
we do we have a few regular people right
I don't know what they do right I don't
know what they make
but they spend every time we do live
streaming still for the store uh they
spend about 2k per show wow and we sell
stuff from 10 blind boxes to 40 50 toys
to you know 150 200 bear rigs they will
spend like two grand wow just everything
show per show that we do twice a week
twice a week live streaming so wow think
about you know look so designer con
is obviously yeah this coming weekend if
you're watching this it'll be this
coming weekend it's in Orange County
we're to Anaheim Anaheim Convention
Center November 18th to the 20th
yeah Friday's VIP night uh presented by
eBay what happens Friday Friday night is
a very limited amount of tickets sold
for VIPs and every box you get a VIP box
uh there's lanyards elimination pins and
you get a limited edition bear break
inside there all for like 90 bucks nice
and then I'm gonna be on that list right
oh yo you got you perfect everybody we
got to stop the interview real quick
we're live in Vegas right now uh listen
fellas if you're watching this and you
need a little extra pep in your step you
know what step I'm talking about I'm
talking about that dick step damn it all
right if you need some help with that
Dickie or uh blue chew is here to save
the day that's right same exact
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but
here's the catch no awkward doctor's
appointments it comes straight to your
door
in a chewable form very discreet
packaging very discreet billing uh you
don't have to go to a random waiting
room while you wait to get your dick
pills from the doctor it's an
embarrassing situation no with Bluetooth
all you do is go to bluetooth.com right
now sign up with the promo code bootleg
that's the most important part when you
sign up with bootleg at bluetooth.com
you get your first month for free you
just got to pay five dollars shipping
that's right you go to Bluetooth you get
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis in that blue True Form your
dick is uh on an all-time high I mean
this thing is [ __ ] booming uh and
then on the other end they just drop
their new mint chewable which has the
same active ingredients as Levitra all
right which is even stronger so if you
really need some help in the dick
Department
bluetooth's got you all right go get a
free month fellas I don't care if you're
not even dealing with any dick problems
maybe you just want to impress somebody
you're about to [ __ ] Hammer all right
go to Bluetooth get your first month for
free right now delivered right to your
doorstep using that promo code bootleg
go do that and let's get back to the
interview so you guys do every year you
guys do one of these yeah so this is
series four artist series four every
year uh so the idea behind it is in 2018
when we moved to Anaheim uh metacom came
and said they wouldn't they're looking
for a North American partner like
convention right yeah so they loved our
show they came out the president came
out so in 2019 we started our first
Artistry so what we want to do with our
platform is we want to give American
artists that usually don't have an
opportunity to put their art on on this
platform because they're from Japan
right so a lot of like for people don't
know bear bricks a Japanese company so a
lot of Japanese artists probably get
mostly Japanese Asia company because
when they see it like their Department
their scouting people they love certain
artists yeah it's a lot of Asian a lot
of Asian artists so what we did is we
decided to put on artist that's
affiliated with designer con that's been
doing designer con for years or done
collab with us in some kind of capacity
and also
um mostly Americans right this year we
have someone from the UK but but he's
been supporting design income for over
10 years wow so Dr a is to the this
thing yeah so Dr a does a lot of uh like
those robot style right Mech uh figures
and he does everything in resin he'll be
a designer con this week uh this week
Bobby hundreds one and then uh Bobby
hundreds that's a cool one you know the
hundred was actually at the designer con
2018 where the Mr cartoon collab and
capsule so they were part of our show
and Bobby's been coming to design con
for over 10 years he will always come
with his son and all that just to have
fun just have fun yeah and then we reach
out say Hey you know we know that you're
an artist yourself like he draws he
designed graphic tees for his brand so
yeah we did this for uh for our show and
then this is the obey the obey guy
Shepherd fairy
so this is one of the uh proud moment I
will say Ben will tell you that it's a
I love obey everybody I think yeah I
mean listen can we talk about iconic and
iconic American artists right I mean all
the way to the clothing line to the yeah
I mean I think back to
the Obama hope stuff yeah yeah yeah and
what's funny is we did not realize that
he's never done a bear break before
and right he's never done one so the
opportunity came I think uh earlier this
year and uh we asked him if he uh was
you know be willing to do something like
this he's seen them he wasn't sure that
he his art will work on this platform
and we told him how a lot of different
artists are playing their art onto this
platform and uh there you go so this is
a basically every bear brick is unique
this is a water dip technology so I've
seen those yeah those are a Vibe yeah so
it's one a big image and then every time
they dip the figure into the process it
lands on there differently so everything
each one's unique every single one's
unique there will be no not not this not
same one the only thing on here that's
uh constant would be the logo on the on
the leg right right here everything else
will be different for every single one
of them wow so this is the 400 and 100
pack and will be exclusively at designer
car this weekend yeah so when people
people show up and they really like uh
is it pretty frantic to get like to get
some of these items you guys do
exclusions on
um our two collectors not crazy people
like sneaker people because you know
sneaker and like like when you when
people go to complex con okay there's a
[ __ ] wild like there's always like
exclusives and you'll see yeah I've seen
people I mean it can get hairy but like
our toy people was a little more
measured than sneaker people uh yes so
uh
we I've been to complexcon obviously uh
there's a diff two different Vibes I can
tell you that for people that have never
been to designer con uh our thing is
when you go there you're gonna meet your
favorite artist if you if you like a few
artists and other artists have like
Gallery openings throughout the year
throughout their career you know they
get busy right so at our show they're
usually chill they're at their Booth
they just want to meet their fans and
they're selling stuff they're selling
stuff there's a lot of them are selling
stuff that
like they brought from their archives
right like I have like Steve I don't
know if you know who Steve Caballero is
yeah of course yeah yeah so I met him a
few years back and then we started
making pins like just for fun like we're
friends skater right yeah yeah but he
he's an incredible artist I didn't know
that he's an incredible artist so he's
been doing designer con ever since I'm
like oh my God you can draw like that
like rap thing style like that that era
and so he he will come and he will bring
like [ __ ] that you've never seen before
but hey I got the skateboard right you
know stuff like that a lot of artists in
this year we have like uh Sean Cleaver
as well so from the skating world
they're artists everywhere they're
artists in every you know part of the
the industry so that's that's what
you'll see designer con hey what up
y'all bootleg Kev gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our newest
sponsor man shout out to the homies at
hardean Las Vegas that's right the
number one dispensary in the whole state
of Nevada let alone in the whole [ __ ]
country so many choices of Premium
cannabis ladies and gentlemen it is like
how can I put this you walk into it you
go to Jardin in Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sense
you'll be like yo bootleg have sent me
they're gonna take care of you at Jardin
when I say selection I mean selection of
the best premium cannabis in the world
the best dispensary there's a reason why
Jardine is world famous follow them
right now Harding underscore Las Vegas
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview what is
your because another thing I feel like
like a surface level toy fan usually
collects Funko Pops yeah because you go
to Target they're there you go like
there's is always Funko Pops wherever
you go right the Disney Store wherever
Etc
um what is your take do you collect
Funko pops uh I don't collect them like
crazy but I do like them uh in terms of
the eyepiece that they have because
there's certain movies great great
movies movies waiting for them to do The
Big Lebowski fun go Pops I don't know if
they've ever done one but I think they
have that's my favorite I mean there's
so many things but like they get every
license yeah they did they they do you
go to the store and you're just like
Jesus they got there's so many you can
it's wild so what what I like about so
we don't really we did one Funko
exclusive a couple years back with Mark
Hamill so his team so we decided to
release two three out of the four as
designer con exclusives so with his team
that that uh we release those three and
they're very limited they're like only a
thousand of each wow design they're like
compared to what you buy at right like
Funko wise that's super limited so we
have like two of them that's a 1000
pieces but for me Funko and then we did
uh in 2018 we did a collab with uh Funko
at metacomp it was funko's 20th
anniversary so we made a bear brick with
them and put it in the cereal so that
year they did a bunch of different
cereal I don't know if you remember yeah
so what we look for designer can look
for we're not Comic-Con we're not like
when they're called those shows we're
not looking for that big Funko Booth
we're looking for an experience in that
Activation so when Funko came to us like
hey we want to build this Supermarket to
launch our brand new product which is
the cereal we're like that's a cool idea
we love it yeah and we collaborate on
that so we're not looking for that like
standards you know you're just going to
any shop you buy a Funko Pop right but
we're not uh discouraging vendors like
we have toy stores from around the world
coming like uh Toy Tokyo from New York
they have a bunch of exclusive with
Funko they always bring some stuff for
designer con and we're not saying that
don't bring that we say yeah it's part
of the world you know it's right but
with Funko for me also it's a gateway
drug it is that's how I see it because
it says now it's what twelve dollars
Funko Pop yeah you get like six of them
I know I got a little thing and then
right yeah but when you come when you're
getting into it a lot of people discover
oh there's different artists there's
different toys and then you get the the
platform like bear break you get uh the
kit robot like these guys that never
been like not from where I'm from like
back in the early 2000s they would
discover and then you kids would be like
oh there's more to just this right so
like I'm hoping I mean we've seen it as
a lot of people collection grow Beyond
past the Funko Pop you know they'll be
like oh I have a thousand Funko Pops now
but now I like the bear bricks I'm gonna
start that right so like it goes up to
the next level your personal toy
collection
what is the most expensive toy if you
were to sell it on the second Market or
re resale market right now that you own
probably
25 30 000. which toy is that I have
three of them
what are they I have three cars one
thousand percent
wow yeah so now it's about 30 25 30 cage
each each
[ __ ] what did you pay for those 300
300 bucks so I
75 to 100K worth of [ __ ] yeah that's
just just in three Toys just three Toys
in my living room in my display case
that's just three sitting there so if
you what would you estimate your toy
collection is worth if you were to sell
it
million I mean I don't know like wow you
know I mean I would say like I would say
if I sell everything I could probably
buy a house
in LA you know like an expensive house
yeah nice house yeah decent sizes
so I would say if I saw everything you
know I would get to me it's in the to me
it's a it's a hobby yeah and it's also
uh an investment you know you buy art
you buy Collectibles you buy sneakers
yeah people buy I mean people buy
paintings people buy yeah yeah exactly
and for me what's funny is um so the
thing I tell people story is Ben is very
uh 2D 3D person right so he he knows a
lot of painters and an artist that does
flat 2D stuff right I'm wasn't that
person I got into it from the toy side
right I got into it from the 3D side so
right so I got to learn by doing
designer con I got to learn different
artists I got to meet different artists
I got to appreciate the 2D stuff as well
so yeah and then I have a print problem
too by Prince original art like I just
bought an original painting off of uh
Ben Frost recently and I'm like
now why did I buy that but it's like you
know so some it just kind of got into
what what I do like I think I mean if
you love what you do that much yeah it's
also your job exactly it's uh you just
gotta you just gotta make sure you don't
you know you save more than you uh spend
on toys you know you're selling the toys
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you tell your partners at
Odd Socks our presenting sponsor here at
the bootleg kit podcast listen Christmas
time is approaching faster than you
think I mean we're like [ __ ] a month
and a half away or some [ __ ] whatever uh
get some Odd Socks for your folks go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and you'll save 20 off at
checkout the most comfortable socks in
the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy
literally the most comfortable sock in
the world I'm holding the [ __ ] sock
right now you can save 20 off plus they
got boxers now baby all right go to Odd
Socks official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview so that's that's the balance I
think yeah when you say what my house
looked like and then what were you
talking about before the show started
like it's it's crowded it's packed I
have hundreds pair of shoes I have
thousands of toys I have hundreds of
bear bricks I have stuff that's not you
know open because I have no room to
display you know but I know I have it
like okay I got a debt stock completely
new sealed in the back in the storage
right like I always want to keep one you
know when when all these things are
limited editions now yes like this
weekend you might be fine a couple
hundred of them yeah but in a year or
two
price gonna double triple because you're
not gonna find them people keep them
imagine 10 years from now I'm telling
you those cause bear bricks I had those
were from 2007 or eight
damn it's 13 years ago
that's 14 years ago right but who knew
like college prices was was going to go
up at that time either too so I just
like them you still have that OG toy the
Stussy one uh yes you still got the
First toy that got you started yeah
still do you have it like in a special
place no it's in a box somewhere it's in
a box so the toy actually belonged to my
cousin got you so I saw it actually with
him and he had it so at that time I
wasn't even like buying anything right I
was just like this is really dope and
then uh he gave it to me a few yeah a
few years ago
um real quick if people want to go to
designer con they're still tickets
there's tickets there's VIP tickets
still VIP tickets still available at
designercon.com but we are we do have a
hard cap but we're not like super
expensive it's like 90 for the VIP but
there is a cap for Friday night uh
usually it's pretty chill Friday night
the only Booth that's probably going to
be a headache is
the metacom booth is always because
people want to get their first shot at
the exclusive and that's what the VIP
night's for
um but yeah we we keep the tickets
really uh affordable it's for the family
so Saturday and Sunday and kids 12 and
under is always free oh wow with a paid
admission that's dope yeah so we never
we have we never charge for kids 12
minutes that's super dope yeah yeah and
at the end of the day kids love toys we
we wanna our whole thing is always been
about
trying to keep as much money in the
attendees pocket to spend with the
vendors and artists right because
they're going to show up a lot a lot of
these conventions are expensive
expensive yeah super expensive like we
don't want that we want to we want to do
what what we can to keep money in their
pockets so they can spend money at the
convention for our our artists and our
vendors and then do you guys have a uh
this 3D retro have a set up there every
year yes yeah um you guys bring it yeah
you know we know somebody yeah so we we
have a few exclusives every year and
then we have uh products from the store
we do special deals right
um and then metacom actually has a brand
new booth that we've been designed uh
with them for the past year and we have
actually uh something really dope I just
saw it this morning actually I haven't
seen it in person really you saw this I
just saw the Box yeah uh we have a three
thousand percent
a size like a so it's like a 10 feet
statue Jesus I have a beverage that's
gonna be at the metacambooth so
I love everybody to come out and check
it out three thousand percent yeah
that's pretty big pretty because what is
the like the the big ones one thousand
okay and then this is 400. got you yeah
and that small one's 100.
so it's 3 000 of that Jesus Christ
it's huge well listen man go get your
tickets uh appreciate you pulling up
when you guys do your stream where can
they go in the Stream and is that on
Twitch uh actually we're on Pop Shop
live okay so uh just follow us on
Instagram at 3D retro I think that's the
easiest when we're we have all that 3D
retro follow designer.com follow
designer con dope stuff going on if
you're a hip-hop head Def Jam and uh DJ
amen are doing their blessed Def Jam
boost yes Def Jam and and eamonn's doing
some stuff hobby DJ and uh I think
amen's trying to convince me to do the
podcast from out there with somebody I
don't trap which we're trying to figure
it out so I think it'll be cool
I think you'll like it yeah you know I I
know I like the convention yeah yeah you
don't know if you want to do it I just
don't know I'm like trying to figure
this out with aiming like okay what do
you who do you want me to talk to there
he's like well we got to figure that
part out I'm like all right well just
let me know man because Def Jam will be
there a lot of people are flying in it's
going to be an easy weekend A lot of
people all over the world yeah there it
is man next week appreciate you playing
up man thank you so much yes sir and
it's this weekend because when you're
watching this it'll be this weekend
coming this weekend November 18th 19th
and 20th in Anaheim Anaheim there it is
designer con go get your tickets thank
you perfect